avec un sujet alors un sujet que l'on
voit hélas encore trop souvent revenir
dans l'actualité
une jeune femme est morte ce week end
victime de violences conjugales elle
avait pourtant alerté la gendarmerie
à plusieurs reprises c'est bfm tv que
nous raconte son histoire
julie du web avait 35 ans et deux
enfants elle est morte dimanche tuée par
son ex compagnon victime de deux coups
de feu lavez le sentiment de ne pas être
prise au sérieux par les services de
gendarmerie
elle les avait d'ailleurs interpellé en
leur disant mais qu'est ce qu'il faut
qu' il faut peut-être que je meure pour
que l'entente n'est que l'on ne me
croient aussi l'ex compagnon de julie et
s'est rendu à la police il a été placé
en garde à vue
une enquête pour homicide volontaire a
été ouverte contre lui alors je rappel
des chiffres qui sont absolument
terribles et en 2018 tous les trois
jours une femme est morte sous les coups
de son conjoint ou de son ex conjointe
trois femmes victimes sur quatre des
voir déclarent avoir subi des faits
répétés ce qui était le cas pour cette
jeune femme qui a fait tout ce qu'il
fallait dans les règles de l'art elle
est allée à maintes reprise signaler le
comportement de son ex compagnon et
visiblement personne n'a pas cessé
lettre morte quoi c'est c'était une
jeune femme qui vivait à île rousse donc
en balagne en corse elle était très
appréciée de plein de monde
il ya plein de gens qui étaient au
courant de sa situation elle était allée
porter plainte son père était allé
porter plainte
elle avait prévenu les gendarmes qui il
pouvait se passer quelque chose qu'elles
pourraient mourir sous les coups sous
les balles de son compagnon c'est ce qui
s'est passé alors on culpabilise tout le
temps les femmes qui sont victimes de
violences en leur disant vous ne portez
pas plainte
vous ne partez pas de chez vous vous ne
vous bougez pas la lave et où la taille
faire alors comment expliquer que cette
jeune femme soit morte par deux balles
de son compagnon moi ça moi ça me rend
complètement dingue et en explorant tous
dingues ne serait pas de sanction
simplement
et là où il ya un problème c'est que
finalement si on disait que les
personnes qui n'ont pas écouté cette
femme elle était après accusé de non
assistance à personne en danger
peut-être que salir murray un peu parce
que il y en a marre de cette histoire de
jalousie de passion et s'est engueulé
parce qu'ils aiment trop etc
drame passionnel les drames de jalousie
ça commence à me gaver donc je pense que
les gens qui n'ont pas répondu à la
demande de cette femme qu'il devrait
concrètement le gendarme qui a pris il
faut qu'ils gagnent pas c'est pourquoi
tu n'as pas répondre mais c'est pas
classe en richesse et plusieurs
gendarmes
bien que les gendarmes ne sont pas
formés et ils ne réagissent pas il s'en
fout complètement
c'est pas normal dans le parc on parle
pas d'une seule personne là on parle de
plusieurs personnes
ton recueillir les plaintes et qu'elles
n'ont rien fait qu'est-ce que vous c'est
quoi la mesure la mesure qu'ils auraient
pu prendre une mesure d'éloignement par
exemple certainement que ça a été fait
le problème c'est qu'il n'ya pas
vraiment de moyens mis à leur
disposition
donc c'est à eux de trouver des
solutions de peut-être faire des rondes
d'aller voir de se déplacer il faut il
faut inventer les moyens quand ils
existent pas salade si la loi ne change
pas les chiffres sont assez effrayant
avec 1,8 plein de sur 10 ans les femmes
qui osent porter plainte y en a eu huit
sur dix qui n'aboutissent pas sarko n'a
que deux vraiment où il ya quelque chose
qui se passe près faut savoir que depuis
le 1er janvier on ne dit pas assez
depuis le 1er janvier il ya trente
femmes qui sont mortes de violences
conjugales
c'est une caisse de quasiment tous les
deux jours c'est le double de l'année
dernière c'est de pire en pire et moi
j'en peux plus d'entendre partout à la
télé une femme sur trois ou une femme
sur deux meurt sous les coups de leur
compagnon sans qu'on ne fasse rien y'a
rien qui ait fait devrait y avoir de la
prévention encore plus sert qu'à partir
du moment où il ya où il ya une femme
qui prend ses voilà qui arrose enfin
aller porter plainte
eh ben on fait de la prévention derrière
et on tape dur voilà à quoi on peut
mettre non tu peux pas tu peux pas faire
ça excuse moi tu peux pas faire ça c est
il là engueuler ils sont engueulés etc
quel va être le motif pour mettre ce
type en prison tant les cartes est ce
que vous voulez dire les menaces comme
un ou des couacs et qu'on invente un
nouvel arsenal juridique exacte avant
même si celui qui existe parce
qu'effectivement les arrêts de jeu 10
l'arsenal existe il n'est juste pas ou
mal appliquées parce que les uns et les
autres ne prennent pas forcément en
compte
et quoi qu'on dise oh c'est simplement
une batte une bagarre d'amoureux il faut
vraiment plus écouter les fans mathieu
vraiment où les femmes violence de
de violence et de technologie et les
hommes aussi qu'ils sont très nombreux
et donc par le passé on a on a
d'ailleurs en voilà vous le voyez ici de
tous ces chiffres qui sont assez
terrible je le disais 19% déclarent
avoir déposé une plainte en gendarmerie
en commissariat de police suite à ces
violences
les hommes représentent 27 % de cas de
violence conjugale 17 % de cas mortels
et en 2017 130 femmes et 21 hommes ont
été tués par leurs partenaires ou ex
partenaire 25 enfants mineurs sont
décédés annonce des chiffres absolument
dramatique
alors on dit à chaque fois que les
pouvoirs publics prennent la bralima
alors y a plein qui sera devenu fragile
un joli l'action qui sont comme ça sur
le pape les résultats après je pense
clairement que l'on peut pas câbles et
où les gendarmes et et tous les gens qui
sont allés poste de police mais qui
prennent les plaintes je pense
clairement qu'ils manquent d'outils
juridiques
donc il faut les leurs données et à
brève durée dit qu'il existe faut
arrêter de mettre la faute sur cette
gendarmerie de façon locale c'est
général il ya 220 mille femmes victimes
de violences par en ayant seulement 20%
de plainte c'est parce qu'elles n'osent
pas elles ne peuvent pas mais si tout ça
explose au niveau des chiffres l'état va
enfin s'en occuper et enfin ça va me
redonner va pas mais c'est le premier de
ces pauvres et services a déjà souffre
c'est pour ça qu'il faut absolument les
led zeppelin elle veut absolument a
déposé plainte notamment le cas de cette
de cette pauvre jeune femme qui qui qui
est morte sous les coups de face ou le
débat la veille de son débat lyon vente
en l'occurrence elle avait fait sa
famille l'avait fait elle avait dit
qu'elle qui allait avoir un drame est
que l avait même dit aux gendarmes qu
est ce qu il faut qu il se passe que je
meure pour que vous réagissez et hélas
l'issue tragédie était là et c'est ce
qui s'est produit donc dites nous ce que
vous en pensez avec le hashtag sécurité
ce que l'appareil législatif n'est pas
assez fort ou au contraire il est assez
fort mais pas assez appliqué
est ce que les gendarmes sont démunis on
attend vos tovo vos réactions sur ce
sujet qui est vraiment un sujet
malheureusement trop récurrent et qui
est absolument dramatique